[Music]
there are three things that every
millennial should know the first one is
that there is no evidence for any of the
stereotypes about us if you look at
entitlement if you look at selfishness
if you look at public opinion polling
there's as much evidence that we're
worse than our parents as there is that
we are we're wolves there is none
whereas there's a mountain of evidence
that things are harder for our
generation than they were for our
parents or our grandparents and that
it's getting worse so how many articles
have you read about how more Millennials
are living with their parents now than
ever there are twice as many Millennials
living on their own making less than
$30,000 a year than there are
Millennials living with their parents we
don't read any articles about that so
what we need to do is acknowledge that
all of these stereotypes come from
anecdotes that they are older people who
have seen a millennial on a skateboard
or have had a intern who was a young
person who they didn't like very much
and have decided that that is
representative of an entire generation
and we need to resist that it wasn't
always like this when my dad bought his
first house he was 29 living in Seattle
he was a university professor and his
house cost 18 months of his salary now
if you're a young person living in a big
city you know that that is science
fiction and the vast majority of America
especially in cities
it will cost you 6 7 10 12 years of the
median salary to buy the median home so
this idea that we're different from our
parents because we have changed is
completely false what has happened is
the economy has profoundly shifted
underneath us housing health care and
education are all three times more
expensive now than they were in 1968
those are the prerequisites of a
middle-class adulthood have a secure
adulthood a real life and our parents
like to point out that things like
refrigerators and TVs are a lot cheaper
and they are that's great but the things
we actually need in our lives are much
more expensive and our wages have not
kept up so one of the things that we
forget and especially our parents forget
is how much cheaper college used to be
when my dad was in college he worked for
10 hours a week in the
Metiria and that was enough for his
tuition and a little bit of his rent
that doesn't sound familiar to anybody I
know and what has happened since then is
the cost of education has gone up
between four hundred and twelve hundred
percent depending on the kind of school
you go to meanwhile minimum wages
haven't really bugged general wages
haven't really budged and the price of
everything else has gotten higher too so
in the early 70s it took around 300
hours of minimum wage work to afford a
four-year education by the 2000s it took
four thousand four hundred hours of
minimum wage work to afford a four-year
education so tell your parents that next
Thanksgiving when they complain to you
about not going to college I think
there's a tendency when we talk about
Millennials and especially when we talk
about poor Millennials to talk about our
choices rather than our options so again
the evidence like did my grandparents
know what their pension was when they
were twenty five I don't think they did
I think that by the time they checked
they had one where as this generation
gets blamed for not saving more for
retirement the reason why that's
considered a huge problem is because
there's no such thing as the defined
benefit pension anymore a lot of our
grandparents have a situation where they
get 80 percent of their last salary for
the rest of their lives that is
non-existent for our generation so we
are now being given the responsibility
of saving up to compensate for the fact
that the economy doesn't take care of us
anymore
we're being blamed for the fact that we
can't take care of ourselves but what
have wages done since 1980
they've been flat what has happened to
the cost of everything it's gone up so
we are being asked to reverse this to
counteract this ourselves when we have
less secure work lessen savings we're
paying more for housing and we're paying
off our student loans and I'm sure that
there are irresponsible Millennials on
planet earth I don't think that they
should be getting the bulk of the
attention or the prioritization when we
talk about what's really happening with
young people what we have is a crisis
where to get onto the job ladder the few
decent jobs left that have health care
that have security that have
pension they all require a college
degree so you have to go to college
basically the college premium how much
extra you earn for going to college is
70% you are an almost double if you go
to college on average then if you don't
go to college so we're in this bind
where you have to go to college or else
you end up in a really bad job for the
rest of your life but then to go to
college you have to go into 80 thousand
a hundred thousand more than that debt I
interviewed somebody for the article
that is paying off three hundred and
eleven thousand dollars in debt I know
you another person who's actually a
bankruptcy lawyer who was paying two
thousand dollars a month's in student
loans after he got out of college and so
when you look at how many of us have
student loans and that we're paying them
off at the time when were early in our
careers were not as established in our
fields we can't afford decent housing we
aren't earning very much at that time
and then we're also on top of that
paying a couple hundred bucks a month
extra that's money we're not saving
that's money we're not putting to a
pension that's money we're not putting
to a home and that extends the period of
what our parents called adolescence but
really insecurity that extends our
period of insecurity into our 30s and
our 40s and so if you look at any poll
of Millennials more than half say they
have put off marriage they have put off
children they put off buying a home
because of their student loans and
student loans are the only form of debt
that you cannot get rid of in bankruptcy
so they are literally inescapable even
if you die in some states your partner
might actually have to pay them off for
you so this is a ball and chain around
the ankle of millions of Millennials and
again it's not a choice that we made
it's the economy that we're in that to
get onto the job ladder you need to have
an education and yet that thing that you
need has gotten more and more expensive
and again we are being blamed for going
to college and majoring in ancient Greek
or something when we should have done
stem but stem degrees cost more I think
it's important to know that everything
that's been done to us has been done to
us in broad daylight which means that we
can roll it back that's the only good
news I'm going to give you everything
about our wages and our housing costs
and financialization and the safety net
these are
thick laws that have been passed other
countries have not done this so we can
actually look into fixing all of these
things I think as a generation we are
finally aging into power and when we
take power we need to not make the same
mistakes that our parents generation did
we need to create an equitable country
where even the bottom is pretty well-off
where we don't have this personal
responsibility narrative where if you're
poor it's your fault and if your schools
were bad it's because you're dumb we
need to end all of that we need to be a
moral society that has a basic floor
underneath every person a level of
dignity beneath which we don't allow
people to fall that's not too much to
ask that's what many other countries
have done as they become more prosperous
we're one of the only ones that has not
had that project and has deliberately
rolled ours back so it's really
important as we age into power to not
think that we need to start everything
from scratch you hear a lot now about
fancy new policy ideas and we have a lot
of systems in place food stamps are not
broken the eligibility for food stamps
is cruel and you cannot spend food
stamps on a sandwich that is we
need to fix that we don't need to start
anew with a whole new structure that is
going to be an excuse for people to cut
overall spending other countries have
just gone through this recently where
they've said oh we just want to make it
easier to get welfare and they use it as
an excuse to give away less what we need
to do is we need to tax the rich and we
need to spend it on public services we
oftentimes get distracted by shiny
objects I think especially on the left
but things like public education let's
pay teachers more
let's have smaller class sizes let's
give principals control over their own
schools let's tax the rich to pay for it
that's fine homelessness let's build
houses for people let's keep people from
getting evicted from their homes let's
allow cities to build homes when people
move there let's tax the rich to pay for
it there's lots of things that we can do
that we already have but we've
systematically defunded them you hear a
lot about things like Hyperloop
now and autonomous cars there's also
this thing called trains and buses that
we have not funded adequately for 30 to
40 years now let's fund lots of trains
and lots of buses and tax the rich to
pay for it it's not that there's not
enough money
it never was that's absurd there is
enough money but it's being distributed
to places where it doesn't need to be
going and we need to start to roll that
back and that has to be our
unfortunately generational project is
reversing everything that our parents
have done to us I think there's this
sense that we're gonna come up with some
magical policy idea that's going to make
this easy it's not going to be easy we
don't necessarily have to come up with
some fancy new idea that's gonna build a
consensus we just have to win we are on
the cusp of outnumbering older
generations we need to take our
political power and use it to create an
equitable country the kind that we wish
we grew up in
[Music]